Perico right I've never tried  Hollandaise sauce how do I know this is  right so that looks like it's a great  start if you aerate it it can take so  much butter if you don't lift up those  egg yolks then it splits basically  breaks so aerate those eggs first and  make sure the heat underneath is not too  hot a question from Steve uh gee pretty  much salt in my bolognese sauce raw  potato will dry out the salt rights no  Steve it won't first of all take one  third of The Bolognese out a touch of  sugar and let it down with a touch of  creme fresh creme fresh will lighten up  the flavor and get rid of that salty  taste Faye rides me internally trying to  figure out how I would make a scotch egg  do I use a hard-boiled egg or do I wrap  it after with the sausage so the  delicate part there try and make a soft  boiled egg and that way it stays nice  and creamy  firm up the eggs and then lay out the  sausage really thinly and wrap it nice  and tightly good question